Let's take a quick look at how to use Cloud
SQL with Compute Engine.
The first step is to create a database.
Go to the SQL section and click create instance
and choose "second generation."
Give your instance a name, and then choose
the region and zone for your instance.
You can now change the instance type and the
storage capacity.
Don't worry, you can change these later if
you want to.
You can also ensure high availability by creating
failover replicas, and you can schedule backups
and maintenance windows as well.
Click "Create," and in a few minutes your
instance should be created.
Go to the Compute Engine section and copy
the external IP address of your instance.
Now go back to the Cloud SQL section, and
click your instance.
Here, go to the Access Control tab and click
"add network."
Give it a name, past your IP address, and
click "done."
Now hit "save."
Go to the users tab, and change the root password.
Now go back to the overview tab, and copy
the IPv4 address.
You can now connect to your Cloud SQL database
just like any other MySQL database.